meanwhile meanwhile did you guys hear
about what saudi arabia announced the
last 24 hours have you have you seen
this or no tyler
okay so go to wall street journal story
or examiner or fox or bloomberg or any
one of them you can go to any one of
their stories okay
so saudi arabia just announced if you
can open that up
saudi arabia considering accepting the
the one instead of
dollars for chinese oil sales okay so
china is plain aggressively coming in
saying hey
we're here
we're waiting
um
can you imagine what happens if saudi
arabia goes away from the dollar which
the dollar has historically been what
the main currency and now they're gonna
take this angle what kind of a look is
that on u.s what kind of a look is that
on the administration what kind of a
look is that for the world what is the
world saying when they see this
oh oh
motive china's officially
the new
powerhouse in charge u.s is getting more
and more and more weaker with the dollar
what do you think about when you see
this tom
man we got to get that vice president
out there to say something nonsensical
you know we got to send her on a tour no
i think this is this is also i think
national security the dollar has been a
storehouse value and also the store sort
of the ruler by which all currencies are
measured it's been the stable currency
and it may be oh well that's an elite
thing to say such an imperialist thing
to say to put your currency out there
but i think it's a security issue
personally
can you pull up the article to read the
whole article uh go to the wall street
journal one this is the hill is this is
this the other one's behind the paywall
okay let me look at this one two nations
have intermittently intermittently
uh discussed the major of a matter of
six years but talk seven twenty 7022
disgruntled over the united states
nuclear negotiations with iran and its
lack of backing for saudi arabia's
military operation and
boom
there you go by the way did you see what
just happened right there
these guys are sitting there negotiating
with iran okay
on nuclear deals and saudi says no
problem i thought we were your number
one ally you're doing that we're going
to china nearly 80 percent of global oil
sales
are priced in dollars and since the mid
70s
the saudis have exclusively used the
dollar for oil training as part of
security agreement with the us
government according to the journal the
talks are the latest in an ongoing
effort for beijing both to make its
currency threat tradable in
international oil markets and strengthen
its relationship with the saudis
specifically china previously aided
riyadh
in construction of ballistic missiles
and construction nuclear power
conservation relations has increasing
fade in recent years crown prince
mohammed bin salah solomon uh initially
put forth a public image as a reformer
liberalizing liberal liberalizing the
country's policies on women right zions
however 2017. anyway so there you go you
sit there and you negotiate with iran
you lose saudi well but the interesting
thing with china is while china's been
uh increasing their their military
support and uh technology uh cooperation
with uh the saudis they've also been at
the same time and are currently iran
yeah increasing their economic uh you
know uh cooperation with iran which if
you look at it they go how do you square
those they don't care that's china as
long as it's in
the xi's regime's best interests that's
all they care about they are very
straightforward it's what you said
before about you know your enemies and
at least honestly yeah you know china
how many billion did china get 400
billion 25 billion exactly is am i
saying it correctly 400 billion 25 type
in iran china 400 billion 25 years well
isn't aren't they kind of talking about
both sides of their mouth right there
whereas
i'm talking about saudi arabia right
here so search it search it or just type
in china iran they're acknowledging the
fact that china is doing business with
iran investing in iran but now they're
they're basically
dissing america because we're having
conversation with iran it's not like
we're having
um economic conversations iran we're
trying to basically figure out this iran
nuclear deal that's went back and forth
left and right for 10 years now but the
the the current administration is very
clear about the you know their essential
their agreement to lift sanctions right
so that that opens the spigot and gets
iranian oil flowing that concerns the
saudis so they're going to look at that
in terms of their own interests um no
it's it's it is in china again you look
at it just their relationship with putin
and putin is it is it or is it
i like that uh you look at their
relationship and again china you know
do you honestly think that they're going
to respond to you know threats where the
u.s may say well you know if you better
not cozy up or cooperate with uh putin
because uh you know that's not gonna end
well for you we're gonna you know impose
sanctions that's not how she's gonna
respond right g is is dealing with uh
russia right now because it he perceives
it as in his best interest
as soon as this thing if it were to go
really ugly you know you're going to see
daylight between them because china's
playing a much longer game and i just
so it is fascinating but this this uh
this conflict apparent conflict between
them dealing with both the saudis and
iran at the same time is i think has
been fascinating hold on i just thought
of something this is a perfect analogy
to what you were talking about
you talked about i trust my enemies more
than i trust my allies
well we know that iran is our enemy
facts okay
what the [ __ ] is saudi arabia at this
point to us
are they our ally are they our strategic
partner are they an enemy did they have
an involvement in 911
that is what's clouding us judgment
right there is i don't know what to make
of saudi arabia saudi arabia is michael
jordan when he says republicans and
democrats buy jordans
everyone buys oil everyone buys oil so
they stay in the middle and they just
say hey listen china buys from us russia
buys from us iran but not maybe not iran
but u.s buys from us everybody buys
friends that's their perspective on us
what should our perspective be
on saudi arabia you buy from them saudi
arabia that's just that it's a business
transaction versus transactional first
of all very good question
it's not a vendor it's a partner what is
the difference between a vendor and a
partner vendor you use once in a while a
partner you use all the time you can't
treat saudi arabia as a vendor us is
treating them as a vendor it's an insult
the way you're handling them as a vendor
i would also be upset if i'm them you
need to treat them as a partner they're
not trying to attack you they're not
trying to do anything to you what do you
mean that how many people from 9 11 were
from saudi arabia
the saudi the saudi government that's
selling oil to you yeah you need to
treat them as an as a partner not a
vendor you can't just go to him and say
you're now an enemy do that so let's
just say you do that since 1973 they've
been using the u.s dollar and now
they're going to go to china now what
happens no i totally understand what
you're saying obviously we want to keep
them on the dollar and be a partner but
you're pointing out
something that
you know this administration previous
administrations it's a very difficult
relationship it's in it because we're
you know people are very conflicted
about it but i agree with the fact that
the world is the way it is
you got to do business with what you got
sometimes you're dealing with with
a government that you look at and go in
an ideal world you're not what we'd like
to deal with of course but [ __ ] it
that's not the way that serves two evils
but and then how do you even
talk to your partner about clearly
mbs muhammad bel salman
chopped up
uh the
journalists
clearly that happened
okay on the world stage everyone
condemned that
all right well you know sorry about
khashoggi let's just get some more oil
going like where the lines are so
blurred with saudi arabia and that's
what makes me what do you do so that's
the question that's why we got cia here
yeah but what do you do in this
situation you would you rather
do you see more
uh saudi arabia having an honest
relationship with you or iran
i i well again do you trust your enemies
you know that they hate you or do you
trust your
supposed partner ally what what are we
buying from iran
nothing we're buying we're buying their
ability to not uh
create nuclear capabilities we're buying
them off okay but by doing that you're
also pissing off saudi correct and
that's the whole sunni shiite dilemma
you know how you do you have anybody in
your family that no matter what friends
no or employees or any customers no
matter what you do you can never make
them happy yes okay i've had people like
you know what i when i when i finally
get to a point that i'm like there is
nothing i can do to make her happy make
him happy make them happy nothing listen
guys let's just go our separate ways
because
there's no
hey let's take them out to them oh
everything goes good next day but you
guys hey let me get them to ski hey let
me do so you're you're never going to
make iran happy but at least you can
keep saudi civil so which one do you
want to look at more as a long-term
person you want to keep relationships
how do you handle the nuclear
negotiations with iran do you just do
you
have to ask the question even if the
guidelines you put in place do you trust
they're gonna follow the agreement
seriously like you think she follows
foreign relation policies seriously
right i mean we had that agreement
between xi and president obama at one
point today okay we're not going to
engage in cyber shenanigans well that
that's a lot of horseshit or we're not
going to engage in economic espionage of
course they are that's how they got to
the you know the the point on the food
chain where they're at right now that's
how they intend to get to the top but i
think with saudi and every other nation
you've got to think from terms of we're
going to act in our own national best
interests what is
important for our national security
what's in our best interests as a nation
that's how every other country does
nothing wrong with that well well we
tend to apologize for it
on occasion um
which is puzzling you're talking about
the obama apology tour around the mid uh
middle east yeah well and and just in
general every time we we act in our own
best centers it's like oh my god i can't
believe we're doing that and you or
you'll get it out in social media and
that sector of the population will be
angst written but um yeah i think with
with with the with the iran nuke uh deal
look how do you how do you deal with
that well you you deal with it by
getting a better deal than we had right
we didn't have full transparency yeah
because they wouldn't allow it so when
john kerry would bang on about trust and
you know verification
well we couldn't verify because we
didn't have access to some of their key
facilities right and that's a problem so
create a better deal or just say fine
we're not gonna i'm sorry we're like
we're not getting that deal and yes
we're gonna then have to have better
intelligence that's gonna
allow us right now
our intelligence on that target is kind
of all over the place right you know
some people say well you know their
breakout is you know a month away yeah
maybe the breakout's 12 months away well
that's there's a big gap there right so
that's that's an important part of this
because at some point maybe the decision
is you got to go in and degrade what
they're doing
um but
yeah you when you talk about the saudis
that's a you hear that all the time in
washington people are always spin spun
up about this you know sounds like we
got to get some cats on the scene in
iran there's snoop around yeah nuclear
facility cats
dogs if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]